let's just do i'll do do
one last introduction
oh yeah all right thanks for coming back
everyone so yeah for the very last
session of the program we're super happy
to have uh doriza sadiq here from
stanford telling us about the role of
conventions in adaptive human ai
collaboration so i'll let you take it
away all right okay thanks for inviting
me excited to be here so
last talk of the program this is very
much practical it's very different from
the talks that you've seen like in this
workshop i'm norsa i am a roboticist i
work on robots working with humans
working with each other uh so a little
bit like not as much theory in this
stuff but maybe there are some insights
that we can learn from when we think
about the theoretical side of things and
i've learned quite a lot during this
workshop like going back to the robotic
side of things i think there are a lot
of interesting insights and making
connections
uh so what do i work on so i work on
robots that generally work with
different types of other agents other
intelligent agents like humans and
you're starting to see a lot of these
types of robotics agents like really
like making their themselves out of
factory floors and working with us an
immediate example is autonomous cars so
we're starting to see autonomous cars
interacting with other drivers human
drivers other autonomous cars
pedestrians
things of the form of service robotics
is really like getting there having
robots in homes trying to help us do
various types of tasks or assistive
robots which is which is an application
that you're actively working on very
interesting very difficult problem so in
all of these applications
we have some sort of interaction between
an autonomous intelligent agent an ai
agent interacting with another
intelligent agent usually a human um and
oftentimes
one way of modeling this type of
interaction in these types of systems is
trying to take a game theoretic
perspective a very simplified game
theoretic perspective where you bring
the two agents together this is a very
common thing that we do in human robot
interaction and you think about the
human building a model of the robot and
having some representation of the
robot's policy the robot state and and
what the robot is trying to do
quite a bit of work in human robot
interaction goes into this like what is
the model of the human of the robot and
then similarly how does the robot model
the human is also like a lot of work
goes into that but once you have that
you pair up these agents and then you
get them to work on a task uh like
playing chess uh this is a made up
example in general we are looking at
mostly like cooperative types of tasks
um and if you kind of pair up these
agents in this game theoretically and do
theory of mind modeling like as we know
that type of recursive belief modeling
is going to be quite expensive so that
is not very practical so in every single
field that does some sort of theory of
mind modeling to actually get it to work
we end up making some sort of
approximation and the approximation is
well let's not solve the full game let's
just cut it at some time step solve an
nth order theory of mind let's do a
stack over a game and and that is maybe
sufficient for what we want to do um
again this shows up in natural language
processing often referred to as
pragmatics or rational speech act shows
up in multi-agent reinforcement learning
as opponent modeling partner modeling
shows up in robotics and that type of
approximation is fairly
good so like this is something that for
example we have done in the space of
autonomous driving where we basically
modeled an autonomous car as an agent
who's trying to optimize its own
objective um so sum up rewards
and that is usually dependent on its
state and its actions so the actions
here are continuous this is steering
angle and acceleration of the car uh and
it also depends on what the other agent
is doing and this other agent is a human
driver so it's a good question to ask is
well how does a human act in the world
and a very common model is to say well
humans are intelligent decision makers
so they're also probably optimizing some
sort of reward function and at some
point someone will come and say well
humans are not exactly intelligent
decision makers so they're not exactly
optimizing a reward function so we start
making approximations about what the
human does and there's quite a bit of
work around modeling humans as these
noisily rational agents who are
approximately optimizing something like
rh
so again a lot of work in the space of
robotics and human robot interaction
goes into learning what these reward
functions event should be like that is
not even clear like what the objective
should be when you're trying to like
optimize for a car driving down the road
is very complicated like how do you how
do you think about comfort and how do
you think about like safety and all
these other objectives that you care
about and how like it's a
multi-objective optimization in practice
and we are trying to pack all of that in
a single reward function and that tends
to be a pretty difficult problem so i
would say like a particular direction in
robotics and ai in general is figuring
out reward design and what this reward
function should be and figuring out how
humans drive like behavior modeling is
also a big part of it but imagine we
have all of that if we have all of that
then we need to solve this game
theoretic interaction
actions of my robot car depends on the
actions of the human actions of the
human car depends on the actions of the
robot as i said that is computationally
very difficult so let's just cut the
game let's assume that my robot is
influencing the human but the human is
observing the optimal actions of the
robot so i solve it as a stack over game
and i go base i go based on that and
then we've demonstrated that this type
of behavior allows us to get behaviors
from autonomous cars that are more
interactive more assertive for example
if a car wants to change lanes
using this type of model what ends up
happening is that our autonomous car
ends up nudging in and by nudging in it
influences the other driver to slow down
and make room for it so let's say that
this driver was going 80 miles per hour
most prior autonomous driving work what
they do is they want to be safe they
look at that 80 miles per hour like oh
this car is going to continue going 80
miles per hour so i can't change lanes
and they don't really change lanes
here's actually a video of a rainbow car
not being able to change lanes because
of exactly that reason
so
it is driving in an exit lane
it starts signaling at some point it's
like doing all the rules of the road
like all the right things to do but it's
not doing anything assertive it's not
doing anything interactive
and because of that it is stuck in this
lane it's exit come back around try
again
which is not that ideal so so it's kind
of silly that you think oh autonomous
car companies for the longest didn't
really have like these types of more
complicated interaction models but they
actually didn't like like for the
longest roboticists we're thinking oh we
just want to build better like good
robots that are good at driving but they
weren't really thinking about
interactions between other drivers and
using this game theoretic model that i
was talking about earlier
we could actually get behaviors like
this where you where you start nudging
in so this driver that was going 80
miles per hour it's not going to go 80
miles per hour anymore it's actually
going to slow down and and because it's
like because this vehicle has a model of
how it is affecting this other driver if
i nudge in front of it it's actually
going to slow down and then that is the
knowledge that we get from this game
theoretic modeling just to be clear i
was wondering i'm also using this window
and i copied here from
[Music]
in their calculations yeah so it kind of
goes back to what should be this reward
that the robot is optimizing and if it
is just safety right like if it is just
that i don't want to get any car like
the best thing you can do is just not
leave the like house right because that
way like you won't hit anything uh but
it's really like a combination of things
and figuring out that right balance is
pretty difficult like coming up with the
right reward function uh like i remember
i was talking to one of these driving
companies and like they were having a
lot of difficulties like when you would
sit in their cars you feel nauseous at
the end of it because it would like
every plastic bag you would see would
slow down because they'd be like oh
there's an obstacle i got to slow down
and like that's very uncomfortable if
you keep like slowing down and breaking
so like again like it kind of goes back
to what should be the reward function we
are optimizing and similarly if you're
not modeling interactions right you want
to like bring down accidents so you
don't want to like get close to anyone
because if you get close to anyone like
being more assertive it is also being
more aggressive and actually changing
[Music]
yeah yeah and that's a very interesting
point yeah because car companies these
days are definitely more on the
conservative side of things which is
interesting because when i see an
autonomous car i know it is going to be
on the conservative side of things so i
probably cut in front of it because i
know it's going to slow down
um yeah okay so this is wonderful right
so i can do game theory type of modeling
i'm not solving the full game because i
was arguing that it's difficult but
these types of approximations work kind
of okay but the thing i want to spend
most of this talk today is actually not
this type of game theoretic modeling
and the reason for that is there are a
lot of tasks coordination tasks
which i don't think in these
coordination tasks we as humans make
game theoretic modeling so for example
imagine you want to move an object like
two robots they want to move an object
together let's say each one of these
robots has partial observability of the
world they only see the obstacles close
to them so they don't like this robot
doesn't really see these obstacles this
other robot doesn't really see these
obstacles
and they want to move this rod together
they don't communicate with each other
they're decentralized they need to
figure out how to do this
this is a successful trial yeah so the
task is don't hit the obstacles and then
move the rod and put it on the table
down to the table not the doors of
course no yeah not about they avoid the
obstacles but they don't see jobs like
they only seem like obstacles close to
them so it's kind of a partial
observability multi-agent
and it's difficult right like if you
want to do the game theory type of
modeling it's actually pretty difficult
to do this but consider two humans
moving a table but people can do this
like easily and this one my dark yoda
are using language tell them to not use
language blindfold them people are able
to like move a table like remove the
cache like very much like easily but
just like feeling the forces so so the
question is what are people doing when
they're moving the cash or moving a
table i don't i don't think they're
doing theory of mind modeling i don't
think we are building these like belief
structures in our head one thing i know
about humans is that they're bound to
rational they have bounded memory and
they're not going to be able to capture
more than a few bits of information in
every interaction so the question we
have is what is it that people are doing
and could we could we incorporate that
in our multi-agent interactions
um here's another example we started
looking at playing a game of air hockey
mostly because phd students wanted to
play air hockey in the lab so we ended
up getting an air hockey table but when
you're thinking about playing a game of
air hockey right like if i were to do
this game theoretic modeling and this
was my partner what would i do i would
look at the action space of this partner
what is the action space of this partner
so the partner is using using their arm
that is a seven degree freedom space so
a human arm has seven degrees of freedom
like any other fancy robot arm has seven
degrees of freedom lives in r7
so if i want to play with this partner i
really need to build a belief structure
in that seven degree freedom space which
again i think computationally is very
difficult
but if i'm playing with the partner i
think what i do as a human is i'm very
effective in capturing the sufficient
information for this task which i would
argue is just a direction of the puck in
this task maybe i'll just look at which
direction the puck is being pushed is it
to the left or right or center and that
is oftentimes sufficient for for me like
just to to play a game over hockey
and at this point you might say okay
this direction is really the intent or
goal and there's a ton of work on intent
modeling and doing belief modeling over
intent so what is the big deal
but most prior work they're like oh
there is a three degree freedom like
space for for intents let's do belief
modeling over that but i'm not assuming
that i have access to this i'm not
assuming that i know what is that
intense space what i'm really like
getting at is we as humans we quickly
figure out what that space is and
ideally i would want to have robots that
are able to do that robots that can just
based on the interactions learn what is
that low dimensional representation that
captures the interaction and use that
low dimensional representation for
coordination so so that is really what
we would like to do
right
it seems like in many games it's enough
for practical purposes to estimate the
amount of you know
uh you know conservatives and more you
know aggression on of your counterpart
does that nutrition hold up
so like that equation holds up i guess
the thing that i'm trying to get at is
let's bring the dimensionality of what
you're like how you're representing your
partner and what i'm arguing is that
humans are really good at getting out of
context and figuring out what that space
that action space is like in a lot of
like uh like a lot of times you sit down
and say oh action space is a and we
assume that that is given but in
practice right like if you take the
action space that it's given that is a 7
degree freedom space of the human hand i
don't want to deal with that i want to
deal with an action space that's much
smaller and the action space is much
smaller i would argue is this intense
this directionality here and the
question is can i figure that out by
just looking at the data can i learn
what that action space is
so
yes the humans have the ability first of
all whenever they participate somewhere
to understand
the action space
is it exactly what are you saying or
that
i'm trying to understand would like
something like to do mindful learning to
do low
low
lower dimensional representation of the
road some problems cover that that's
yeah that's it i'm arguing humans are
really good at that i'm arguing maybe we
can try to do that maybe we can do some
sort of dimensionality reduction on the
trajectories and maybe that will give us
the space that we need to look at and
the dimensionality reduction in the
previous example is that the arm has
seven
uh cycles but you would like to i just
look at that direction okay i just put
that direction in practice and i don't
want to tell the robot to just look that
direction because that's a lot of
information so the robot or direction is
the thing that matters it might be
something else in a different scenario
all right so um
yeah so i'm
going to refer to this low dimensional
representation as a convention i'll come
back to why i'm calling it
all right so we decided to do this with
two robots so we have an ego agent this
is my robot that i'm planning for this
is the robot that i really want to play
this game and i have this other agent
i'm calling it other agent because like
what i'm doing is not making assumptions
about this being cooperative or
competitive it could be an opponent it
could be a partner
um and this other agent uh it's
following a policy um it has seven
degrees of freedom so the policy from
the perspective of the ego agent is the
seven degree freedom space it doesn't
even observe that but i'm telling you
guys that this other agent is really
pushing the puck either to the center or
to the right or or to the left so so i'm
telling you guys that is the policy that
this other agent is following what the
ego agent is seeing is a trajectory that
trajectory is a sequence of state and
actions and reports
states are the states of the puck states
of its own robot like its own joints um
actions are its own actions like what
the ego agent is doing again it's not
seeing anything about the other agent
and it's his rewards so was i able to
block the puck or was i not able to
block the puck so it doesn't really
observe anything about the action space
of the other agent okay
um and what does the other agent is
doing it's actually not like this is not
a competitive scenario this is not zero
sum what this other agent is doing is
following a very hand coded policy it's
a history dependent policy what it is
doing is it's pushing the puck and if it
gets blocked
it's going to try out a different
direction if it pushes the puck towards
the right it gets blocked it's going to
try left or center in the next iteration
so that is what i'm hand coding for what
the other agent is doing
if i wanted to like do to make this
competitive this is kind of rock paper
scissors the best thing the other agent
should have done was play randomly i'm
not doing a competitive setting here i'm
actually like putting a partner model
so then the question is how do i learn
this low dimensional representation that
i'm talking about so so what we do is we
take a trajectory a trajectory is this
tau at episode k minus one
and then what we try to do is we try to
encode this trajectory into a low
dimensional representation z k and i'm
going to refer to this zk as the latent
intent this is what my ego agent thinks
the other agent is going to do next this
is what my ego this is really like
trying to capture that dimensionality
that i was talking about earlier and how
do we make sure that
zk at episode k is learning the right
thing from an episode of data well the
way i make sure that happens is by by
training this objective like training
this using using a prediction loss so so
basically what that means is i'm going
to look at an episode of data episode at
k minus 1 a sequence of trajectories i'm
going to try to encode that into a low
dimensional representation
and using that low dimensional
representation i try to predict what
will happen next what would the next
episode look like
it's an auto encoder like architecture
yeah exactly it's not doing
reconstruction it's doing prediction so
it's taking the k minus one episode and
trying to predict what will happen next
but it is very much an autoencoder like
architecture
um and the reason this would do
something reasonable is that if i see my
trajectory and i'm the ego agent and i
know what i am doing and i know the
state of the world for me to predict the
next tau
the only thing i need to know is what
the other agent is doing
and the ck is trying to ensure that that
is captured in a low dimensional like
space it's like brought down into a low
dimensional space
i mean if you just put one one deep
network wouldn't it also like learn a
simple function kind of like why did it
gain you right to reduce the
dimensionality yeah
second yeah it is a lower dimensional
space to deal with and this zk can have
dynamics right like this like the way
that i defined the dynamics of this dk
earlier was that you push the puck if it
gets blocked you're going to push it
towards a different direction so in some
sense in this low dimensional space
there also exists this dynamics and
for like by living this space like i can
easily like capture that dynamics and
non-stationarity of the other agent in
some sense in this lower dimensional
space so so that's like part of the
reason and it's just that it makes the
space that you're dealing with like a
simpler space if i had like infinite
data and i was just running like
reinforcement learning it would probably
be able to do this too but this just
like helps me to bring down um
complexity
yeah i guess the notation so uh
like uh
oh yeah so what are the the water
collected in the end or
at every step of the internet yeah it's
episodic over and over so so episode is
horizon age so so it would be like a
horizon um
type of data can you parse this
yeah yeah that's right
yeah so basically we're trying to learn
this encoder and decoder the parameters
of the encoder and decoder are p and psi
and what we're trying to do is we're
trying to predict
the log likelihood so so it's a lot like
we did last predicting the future and
for predicting the future we remember
the way i was writing tau was a sequence
of state state actions and rewards and i
know my own actions so so the things
that i'm trying to predict is what will
be the state at t plus one and what
would be the reward that we get actually
like it would be the reward at that
particular t so so that particular time
step given my previous state given the
actions that i've taken and given the
full trajectory horizon h that i've seen
in my past applications
yeah
so can we see the dimensionality
somewhere in that objective
i mean in this work you're not
hardcoding it in this work it's actually
learning like a continuous four
dimensionality we have some follow-ups
where you're learning categorically it's
like we're learning like three
dimensions and you're actually like
including that but yeah here we didn't
and actually like it is learning a low
dimensional z that we think is probably
those directions but it is actually not
my very first of all like it's not like
when i look at that disease
um in this work we didn't make a
category cultivating things in some
parlors we have had versions of it so it
is again a vector of seven whatever
i don't remember what the dimension is
but it's lower dimensional like it's not
seven
it's not in r7 it's actually the word
image i think
it might even be like a single
continuous section i don't i don't
remember what exactly like there is an
answer to the question that from seven
we went to one yeah yeah but it's not
like discrete it's a continuous thing
like that's what i meant by not being
categorical because i could have made
this to be just left right center
and like i could have made
in a few slides i'll get to like that
differentiation that i'm making because
in some settings we are literally like
going to three discrete things but here
all i'm saying is it's a continuous but
lower dimension
so what is the exact observation agent
gets is it like a camera input or yeah
so the observation that it gets is it's
uh yeah so it sees where the location of
the [ __ ] is so so it has like it
basically like it takes for the pockets
and it's like it basically looks at its
own distance to the pump and it also has
like its own state basically so but it
doesn't observe like the the arm moving
yeah
like i know it's like it's all in my arm
right so but it doesn't hear anything
about it so it's not also like the
opposite arm has
separate policies to do the same thing
yeah yeah the opposite aren't fully
assembled okay it doesn't know like okay
all right
okay so
once i have this representation i'm
doing basically is representation
learning from some experienced buffer
i'm getting this zk
once i have that i can use my favorite
planner to plan with that and in this
work what we are doing is we are
wrapping this inside a reinforcement
learning loop meaning that what we're
doing is we're just maximizing expected
return and this expected return is going
to depend on disease that we are
learning these these low dimensional
representations that you're learning so
our policy is really conditioned on on
states and and these diseases that are
coming out of this representation
learning component so there's kind of
like two learning loops happening here
like feeding into each other there's an
iterative process happening here i try
to maximize my expected return based on
whatever estimate of z that i have right
now that generates a policy that policy
generates some data that data goes into
my representation learning component
from that i learn a new z and i'll pass
that in and i keep doing and that's why
the z can actually change over time the
z can have dynamics
so so do you have to have to look so you
can just you know
learn the compression
and we didn't we practically weren't
able to get that to work there's also
like yeah this is the fact that the z is
keeps changing so we kind of like wanted
to have the evolution of that scene uh
but you could technically probably like
put it in
practically like it made things easier
to be in this iterative process um and
what that gives us is that gives us this
agent that can react to other agents so
uh let me show you a very simple point
mass example and then i'll show the uh
air hockey thing afterwards so this is a
very simple point massive example i have
i have an agent let's call that my evo
agent that's like my evil eagle robot
that i was talking about earlier i don't
think i can see it but there's a circle
here
um and there is this other agent that
moves around the circle okay so uh the
setup is if my evo agent is inside of
the circle if it like does a trajectory
and at the end of the horizon it is
inside of the circle my other agent
moves counterclockwise but if it ends up
outside of the circle my other agent
moves clockwise so it's a very made-up
example that we are creating here what
are we trying to do we're trying to my
ego agent what it is trying to do is
it's trying to like capture this other
agent as quickly as possible so that is
what it is basically trying to do
okay so if you're using soft actor
critic soft actor critic like
state-of-the-art reinforcement learning
doesn't really capture a model of the
other agent we are starting from this
point and because it doesn't model what
is happening with the dynamics of the
other agent it kind of like goes in the
center here and and it's it doesn't it's
not really like able to capture the
other agent
but if you're using this algorithm
really learning and influencing latent
intent what ends up happening is that we
end up building a model of how this
other agent is moving right like if i go
outside it makes sure it kind of gets
the dynamics of the other agent to be
flipped moving counterclockwise to
clockwise and vice versa so so it learns
a strategy that it kind of like goes
outside
and then it's able to capture capture
the other agent because it realizes by
going outside right like i can i can
have a model of what the other agent is
doing and based on that it's able to
capture
but the result of this is the it has a
lower dimensional representation so i
can do more exploration so what is the
yeah yeah so so basically it has a low
dimensional representation that kind of
is clockwise counter-clockwise in this
very simple setting and because of that
yeah like much lower samples you can
actually like realize that by going out
you're going to capture the other
um in the game over hockey after four
hours of training this is training on
the robots we are able to basically
model the partner and be able to block
the epoch no matter where it is sent
which is again a difficult task to get
these systems or just four hours of
training on the real life but it's it's
pretty like difficult to get that to
work so so again if you look at success
rate if you use software critic um what
it ends up doing soft doctor critic is
it learns how to block like it learns
how to go towards one direction maybe it
always like goes to the left because it
learns that block stocks once in a while
but like using using lilly we are able
to get a success rate around 90 because
we can really capture this model of the
partner in an effective way
all right so um
so what have i been talking about so far
so i've been talking about basically a
way of doing dimensionality reduction
and modeling the partner strategies
using these low dimensional spaces and
then doing reinforcement learning based
on that low dimensional space and that
helps us to coordinate and react
interact better
but one interesting thing that we can do
that can maybe help us to go beyond this
uh is to optimize for long horizon
objectives right like if i just put a
sum outside of this expectation then
instead of optimizing expected return
like within an interaction i would end
up optimizing it across multiple
interactions that i have
and if i optimize expected return across
multiple interactions then that allows
me to actually leverage this dynamics of
the z that i was talking about earlier
and that allows me to not just react but
also influence the other agent
so
in this in this game that i was showing
earlier right like if i want to capture
this other agent very quickly wonderful
lily what it does is it tries to like
model the agent it goes and captures it
but the best strategy that lily can do
is for lily to to really influence the
agent to be as close to it as possible
and capture it as close to it as
possible because the agent is not
starting from the center station is
starting from top here so the best thing
that it can do
is to in some sense like influence
this other agent to like move towards it
and
by optimizing for the long horizon
objective like what is happening is i
can i can move out in ways that kind of
like get the other agent
counterclockwise and get to me quickly
so i can capture it more more
effectively
okay
what was
optimizing multi episodes because when
you are optimizing multi-episode you
realize how your actions are going to
influence the other agent you start
learning the dynamics of what the how
your actions are influencing the
dynamics of the other agent
if i'm going this way the other agent is
going to go that way so i need multiple
episodes to realize
that dynamics
yeah yeah well yeah the way that we are
including it so so yeah the reason we
are optimizing over multi episodes is
that we get we learn that dynamics so
then in test time when we run it like we
know exactly what to do to get the other
agent to end up at a place that is
useful for us
why do you need to use the absolutely
why can't you just do it in one very
very long episode
it's really like i guess like a
practical choice here so the way we are
yeah the way we are formulating this is
that like for example in this case right
like the way i encoded the dynamics was
if you and an episode is that you either
end outside of the circle or inside of
the circle and that affects which
direction the other agent is going so
that's how i kind of like encoded how
the other agent is being affected but
um
yeah you could probably have like a
really long episode and get these types
of behaviors but it's probably just
cleaner
so the
critic here none of these examples would
have any memory of the previous episode
right
yeah so it's not slightly unfair oh yeah
one could argue that it is
what would you expect would happen if
the sac system did have memory of the
video i think
example so the way that we created this
idea of influencing was that you
artificially made it so that the robot
agent is blocking the puck on one
direction on the left it is going to get
higher rewards so get the reward of plus
two if it blocks the puck on the left if
it blocks the puck anywhere else it gets
a reward of plus one so the eagle agent
really wants the puck to go on the left
because it's like really like good at
that for like whatever reason that we
are making here
we were making it artificially so that
is a better report i'm just trying to
show that if you artificially make it
like that you can influence the other
agent to push the puck more often
like that that's what i'm trying to do
in practice you could imagine that maybe
your robot is really good at going to
the left because
you could artificially make it so that
i'm not even artificial like practice
right there are like some actions that
are easier for the robot
just in the interest of time uh why
don't we keep the rest of the questions
for out at the end of the talk uh i can
i have three sections i can make it one
section
you're good yeah
how much time um
okay
tell me when to stop i can't stop
anytime sounds good um all right so just
like going back to this figure right so
when we are doing this influencing it
actually takes a little bit longer for
it to
uh converge but what ends up happening
is that with influencing you can really
get the puck to more often go to the
left as opposed to uh the other case
without influencing where you're you
don't you're not really influencing the
other agent like no matter where
like
your actions are not going to influence
where the puck is being pushed it can go
uniformly to any of this direction
all right so what i've been saying so
far is that when you're interacting with
other agents oftentimes humans i haven't
shown anything humans here
but when you're interacting with other
agents maybe human partners or robot
partners they're often non-stationary
and by non-stationary what i mean here
is that their actions are influenced by
our actions like even the car example i
was showing right like when we nudge in
front of the other vehicle that vehicle
slows down like us nudging in front of
them is going to like be the thing that
influences them so when we have these
non-stationarities one way of capturing
that is by trying to do it do this low
dimensional representation and having a
latent representation of the other
agent's intent and really leverage that
for reacting and even like influencing
the other agent and what lily is doing
is kind of like a version of that
so um
so that's wonderful but one thing that
we started thinking about and this is
this is maybe not very practical but i
want to like briefly on two slides talk
about it is that
when you're talking about these types of
non-stationarities right like
that is oftentimes a problem in this
multi-agent oral situations right we
have this other agent we need to figure
out what is the dynamics of the other
agent what what are they trying to do we
also need to focus on learning and doing
our own tasks
and if non-stationarity is the problem
i mean like a very simple question to
ask is can we get rid of it can we
reduce non-stationarity
so here is a fun example so imagine that
you have you have a house that is very
messy and you have you and your partner
you want to clean this house
and you want to wash the dishes and you
don't know how to wash the dishes you
have to like learn how to wash the
dishes but then your partner is in the
kitchen too so you need to like deal
with your partner now and what your
partner is trying to do and that can get
really confusing
so one way of doing this task that makes
it a lot easier is if you could lock
your partner in the room
then your life would be so much easier
because you can really like focus on the
task of like washing the dishes and your
partner can focus on like cleaning the
room or doing whatever
so so that's the idea like role
assignments in general is a way of
reducing non-stationarity if you can
come up with these like roles like that
would be really a good way of reducing
non-stationarity having having an easier
task
and and one question is maybe if if we
optimize like how do we get role
assignment if we optimize for
stabilizing the partner like if i want
to clean this house if i optimize for
making sure that the other agent is not
moving so much is actually like stable
then i could potentially end up with a
simpler task to solve and then that is
kind of like the idea that you're trying
to get at here so so i want to just talk
about this again over one slide nothing
i don't want to like talk about this in
too much detail but the idea is we can
do the same sort of representation
learning that i was talking about
earlier this time like it might be
categorical event right like the disease
that we are learning
but once we learn it the objective that
we are optimizing in our reinforcement
learning it could simply be a
combination of achieving the task like
whatever task objective that we had
before and stabilizing the partner and
by stabilizing the the partner what i
mean is we had this low dimensional
representation this z and we can make
sure that that z doesn't change so much
we can make sure that that z doesn't
move so much across across interactions
this is a very difficult thing to train
because i'm trying to learn disease and
not only i'm trying to learn disease i'm
trying to keep them stable too i'm
trying to like not get them changed as
much
but but this very kind of simple
objective of stabilizing the partner as
well as like trying to like achieve the
task together is actually like pretty
useful for a lot of collaborative tasks
so we've actually demonstrated this
working across a number of domains where
you can actually have like higher task
reward as well as higher stability
reward in driving tasks or robotics
tasks or simple like pursuit division
type point mass point mass type of tasks
and then here i'm comparing this
algorithm silly
stabilizing and influencing learning in
the latent intent compared to lilly what
i was showing earlier uh and a number of
other baselines merrill for example is a
surprise minimizing rl algorithm so what
what smarl does is actually interesting
it's trying to minimize surprise over
the environment what we are doing is
we're trying to in some sense minimize
surprise in the partner policy so we're
trying to keep the partner more
stationary
and by keeping the partner more
stationary right like you're able to uh
do interesting things so going back to
this point mass example um i'm changing
this so the agent is not moving
continuously around the circle it just
jumps around and i'm actually changing
it so if you end up outside of the
circle the agent doesn't change to move
around it like gets like it's actually
like stays like it becomes stable but if
you end the
episode inside of the circle it moves
clockwise so if you do something like
this again soft actor critic doesn't
really know what to do it kind of gets
stuck in the middle stable what stable
does is it just tries to stabilize the
other agent so it just realizes that if
it goes outside it makes the agent
stable
what lilly does is it does partner
modeling it's actually able to capture
it but it keeps like jumping around it
doesn't really stabilize the partner but
what silly does is it actually goes out
and stabilizes the partner and then
afterwards it goes and captures it
and the reason i'm interested about this
i think this stabilizing idea is
interesting is i think it even like goes
beyond these multi-agent interactions
like
like for example like a common robotics
test that we are interested in is by
manual manipulation so like how do we
use two arms to to like do a task like
cut a stake like why do we need two arms
to cut a stake like if you think about
it like why don't you use just one arm
to cut a stick like the whole thing the
other arm does is it holds the stake and
why does it hold the stake because me
predicting the dynamics of the stick
it's a very difficult task if i want to
do that right if i hold the stake i
don't need to predict the dynamics of
the state the stake it's actually a lot
easier it stabilizes it so so i think
this idea of stabilizing part of the
environment or part of the
non-stationarity of the environment it's
a very common idea that shows up in a
lot of bimanual tasks and
why manual manipulation is difficult and
that's something that you're actively
working on and i think the stabilizing
idea could be one way of going about
that
all right so uh
let me summarize so kind of the last
point is that if non-stationarity is the
problem and in multi-agent rl maybe we
can reduce on stationarity and one way
of reducing non-stationarity is maybe
stabilizing the other agent
um
i think i'm gonna
skip things
um
maybe let me just
tell you what the problem is okay so so
i had
i don't want to go into details anymore
because i probably don't have that much
time but um let me just define a couple
of other problems that we are interested
in just just to tell you about these
problems and then i'll wrap up
afterwards so so building on top of this
idea of these low dimensional
representations these conventions that
we have
one thing that in general is also pretty
interesting in this human robot human ai
interactions is what happens over
repeated interactions what happens when
you pair up agents and they want to
coordinate with each other over multiple
runs for example i might have alice and
bob here and alice and bob are trying to
put like their blocks to build some sort
of block architect structure and i might
have again partial information meaning
that maybe in this case bob really knows
what we are trying to build but alice
doesn't know what the goal configuration
looks like and it's a collaborative task
they need to do this task together the
first time i pair of alice and bob no
reason for them to be able to do this
task because like alice doesn't know
what to do bob doesn't know how to
signal to alice but if i pair them up
over multiple runs after 20 runs right
like they would be able to build up a
convention a low dimensional
representation that they build together
to be able to do this task for example
like in this case like what bob can do
is bob can put the red block at the top
corner here alice will just observe it
bob moves the red block to the bottom
corner and just this transition is
something that is going to help alice to
know where to put her blue block and i
would be able to do this task and what
is this is an arbitrary convention that
they have come up with this is a
collaborative setting they could have
come up with any other signaling
strategy and they came up with this
after multiple repeated interactions so
a question that we are interested in is
in these collaborative situations where
we have arbitrary number of good
solutions like how do we come up with
like how do we build these conventions
with other agents including humans and
could we build ai agents that can
coordinate with humans and build
conventions that are actually meaningful
with humans um and these conventions
like we see them all over right like and
we see them in our driving behaviors
like there are different equilibria that
we end up at driving on the right side
of the road or left side of the road
that's definitely an arbitrary choice
that we have come up with um that's
again like either one could be a good
solution uh but uh that's a convention
that we have built up built up so
ideally the question is how can we build
ai agents that can do that
i'm not going to talk about how we do it
but i guess at a high level we are
coming up with a modular architecture
that tries to separate
what is special about the task and what
is special about the partner and by
separating them it is able to learn
partner specific conventions
um and uh i missed kalisha's talk what
she might have talked about hanabi and
overcooked and these types of
did you talk about on avian no you
didn't talk about
you talk about korea yeah but the type
of games that you're interested in are
like these types of coordinations like
game of thrones or game of overcooked uh
like game of overcooked is something
like this where you pair up agents and
you try to like get them coordinated
each other and on these games like what
we are interested in is could we adapt
to new partners effectively and quickly
by separating out conventions and rules
specific parts of the game and we
actually demonstrate that you can do
that in these coordination tasks and
similarly if you work with the same
partner could you could you adapt to new
tasks more effectively with the same
partner and you kind of demonstrate that
that is also possible
um
so this was kind of my second section
that i skipped over very quickly and the
last section let me also very briefly
mention this last section and promise
i'll wrap up after that
the last section is something that i
just added to
think about how we formalize some of
these some of these types of multi-agent
problems so one way of going about
formalizing this is formalizing it as a
collaborative multi-arm bandit so what i
mean by that is uh well we have like two
agents maybe we have a leader and we
have a follower leader let's say like
similar to the last example it was our
bob right literacies leader actually
like observes like all the rewards then
arms are pulled the follower here has
partial observability meaning that maybe
with some probability it sees the
rewards and it doesn't always like see
the reward when an arm is being pulled
and they take turns and and that is uh
kind of like the reward structure that
we are we are setting here so um
standard way of going about this is to
say well we have a centralized algorithm
we do ucb and with a centralized ucb we
are going to have logarithmic regret
wonderful but if i have decentralized
ucb meaning that these two agents don't
talk to each other there's no reason for
that to work and that actually gives us
linear regret
the reason for that is if my leader is
sees all the information my leader might
think that this is the arm that we gotta
get right like this is the arm that my
leader has converts to so my leader is
going to choose a row my leader is a row
player it's either going to choose the
top row or the bottom row so my leader
decides to choose the top row because it
really wants this arm but my follower
because it's like it doesn't see all the
information it might be still in the
exploration mode and my follower might
really want to explore
this arm so my follower really wants
this arm so my follower might decide to
pick this column
and the mismatch basically ends up
giving us an arm that none of them
really wanted so we could end up with
these suboptimal situations where like
we end up in arms that no one really
wanted and because of that decentralized
ucd is just going to give us give us
linear regret the question is could we
do better in a decentralized way
and what we have demonstrated in this
work is a very simple algorithm and kind
of like analyze a very simple algorithm
that does this partner modeling in this
setup so this very simple algorithm
basically says hey leader you just do
your ucb don't worry about anything you
do your ucb you just take an arm but
take it l times and the the hard work
here really goes for the follower so
what the follower does is it basically
tries to build a like distribution of
what the leader is trying to do so it
looks at the
latest actions of the leader it
constructs a distribution of what the
leader is trying to do and then within
that it tries to do its own exploration
and its own ucp so that is literally
like the idea of this algorithm is very
simple follower is doing the smart thing
leader is just doing normal ucd and we
demonstrate that this algorithm actually
has logarithmic regret
um i think it would be interesting to
like think about smarter ways of doing
this we tried to make the leader smarter
to do something smarter than just doing
ucb and try to teach
but we weren't able to show anything on
that
so in general i think this idea of
collaborative multi-armed bandits is a
is an interesting way of formalizing
some of these multi-agent collaborations
coordinations that i've talked about
earlier uh and yeah like would be cool
to to have better strategies for the
leader than what i just showed uh or
have like ideas around learning
algorithms that can uh get us uh these
types of behaviors uh we have
demonstrated this on a real robotics
example and even in practice you start
seeing the difference between these two
algorithms so the regret is not just
like asymptotic it's actually like you
actually see this within the different a
difference between these two types of
algorithms we didn't look for the
interactions
um
and i think yeah we should have more
intelligent leader strategies and
potentially generalize some of these
ideas to mdps
all right
can i say one last thing dylan
all right
so okay so i've talked about this idea
of partner modeling right like i think
partner modeling is pretty important for
human robot collaboration human ai
collaboration i talked about it in the
setting of low dimensional
representations as an effective way of
modeling the partner i talked about
stabilizing that as a better way of
coordinating i very briefly talked about
repeated interactions and then
collaborative multi-arbandits as a way
of maybe formalizing it and being able
to give some sort of guarantees nothing
i showed worked with actual humans
everything i showed those two robots
working with each other two ai agents
working with each other let's see how
things work with actual humans so this
lily algorithm was showing 90 success
rate if you pair it up with an actual
human it the success rate goes to 70
and this is a human that is trying to be
as close as possible to that robot
strategy so it's not even trying to be
intelligent this is this is a human that
is trying to be exactly imitating what
that robot was doing and even then
success rate gets dropped because human
behavior has a lot more variability than
what we see in the robot behavior the
friction like the push is going to be
slightly different different force
friction is going to be different that
will mess up everything
similarly is the behavior that other
people have seen this is work from
berkeley where they showed that if you
do self-play in this overcooked behave
like environment it's just not going to
work with humans because humans build
different conventions so the conventions
that i talked about it's actually it
matters if it is human conventions and
in a lot of these types of work what we
end up doing is we end up modeling the
human as this intelligent decision maker
that is doing these game theory type of
models and we kind of like model the
human as the best robot decision maker
that we know
and then what we do is when we do human
studies we ask our humans to be as
robot-like as possible this is like a
very common practice in this field which
is very unfortunate and i feel like it's
becoming more and more of a problem like
even in simplest robotics tests that we
are interested in like
learning how to push an object robot
generated data is very different from
human generated data and messes up our
algorithms so much so in general i think
we need to like look back at our
assumptions and like what it is that
humans are doing um and model that a lot
more carefully than just assuming
they're these intelligent decision
makers um as an example i think why
people are bad at playing chess or
solving a math problem is a very
different issue than why they're bad at
flipping a pancake or finding their keys
from their backs and i think there are
different types of suboptimalities that
we really need to formalize and
understand and we are doing some work
around capturing these suboptimalities
and thinking about active teaching
demons
uh with that i would like to thank the
group
yeah i can take any questions
thanks a lot
[Applause]
all right i thought there are a bunch of
questions uh let's see oh cosis yeah
yeah so i wanted to revisit your very
last point about modeling humans so i
guess like i i'm not really understood
the point is the point that uh humans
are much smarter than what you
model them as a being
when you see when you try to learn
policies no i think what is happening is
not the um i was going to play this one
sec
so here is an example of how humans are
different from robots when they are
pushing an object so um
so there's argument from cognitive
science that when people are doing
simple steps like pushing an object
they're not just pushing an object
they're doing probably five other things
at the same time they're thinking about
the dinner that day and they're like
paying attention to something else and
because of all these different processes
that are happening people are not just
pushing the object they might like they
have random pauses when they're pushing
an object they have like these um and
and you might treat it as noise like so
far like the the field the way that they
have been treating it as that human data
is all just noisy it's just a noisy
version of that robot data and if you
just add enough noise that will capture
it but it turns out that it is more than
that it's actually like not just noise
it's a very systematic type of noise so
um there's a lot of robotics work that
shows that things work wonderfully on
scripted data the moment you add robot
data performance goes down no one got
human data performance goes down because
it's just not from the same distribution
and you have these out of distribution
issues this is one example
of like the type of differences that
human data has it's just more variable
but the other argument that i was trying
to make is that
that variability really depends on the
type of the task like sometimes it is
because they have partial observability
and maybe like they don't know how to
solve the game or go down the game tree
sometimes it's because they have limited
time and they're doing the suboptimal
thing within the time that they have or
they have limited memory they can't
really capture everything like in their
memory so there are different reasons
inductive biases that could cause humans
being suboptimal and i'd argue that
we've got to like model that it's not
the same thing you know but i guess
there's a counterpoint to that which is
sort of like that
if i'm cooking together with my robot
like in the same way that you know like
when i'm making queries to google i
adapt the way i ask google so that
google gives me good answers
like in some you know at least
collaborative tasks i could imagine that
kind of like yeah when i'm cooking
together with my robot
i will you know like you know you know
my behavior will be mal like is
malleable and it's gonna try to bring up
the best of my robot uh that i can bring
up right
so i think that's to some extent and it
depends on the complexity of tasks so
there are two versions of this like what
i've been talking about here or on the
previous slide is not a collaborative
setting it's more of oh i'm collecting
human data and i'm trying to learn
intelligent behavior from that what
you're getting at which is like the
collaborative thing is something similar
to this overcooked thing right like so
if you pair up two agents right like
maybe you pair up two ai agents and they
do self-play and they come up with the
best strategy of doing things now you
pair up that ai agent with a human and
you would expect your human to adapt and
if it is a simple task the human might
actually adapt like okay this is a
convention that you have come up with
i'll go with your convention but if it
is actually complicated if that
convention is complicated then i think
it becomes harder for the human to adapt
for example going to uh this block
example that i was showing earlier
like this example
like this convention is such an
unnatural convention to like for like
bob to put the block here and then move
it down here and that being a signal for
the human to like do this other task and
that could be like a very unnatural
thing and could be if i make this block
to like i don't know three by three like
structure as opposed to two by two like
people start like losing track of these
conventions that are maybe optimal from
the perspective of two ai agents being
paired up with each other so that's why
i would argue that these conventions
should be kind of like guided by how
humans build conventions
oh yes so thank you very interesting um
so with regards to the first part the
lily and the silly part so the sac also
has a function approximator who could
basically learn a model of the
environment the lower dimension model
but i guess it doesn't because the
reward signal is too sparse so basically
you give it an intrinsic motivation
right to predict the environment
and to you know influence environment
and later also stabilize the environment
so is is is this work framed in in terms
of like intrinsic motivation or
curiosity or because maybe i missed it
at the beginning of your time yeah so
there are kind of two parts to it the
lily part is not really like doing any
reward shaping in some sense right the
lily part is just doing partner modeling
it's just coming up with an effective
representation of the partner and that
partner is changing over time so it's in
some sense capturing that change over
time in a very like kind of efficient
way and it's basically doing that the
silly part is exactly that it's
basically a reward shaping approach and
that reward shaping approach the shaping
term is is the stabilizing term and yeah
it is really an instance of that type of
that type of work okay yeah thanks
any other questions
all right maybe we should uh stop it
there so let's thank darcy again
[Applause]
all right that kind of brings us to the
end of the workshop so i just want to
say you know thanks to everyone for
coming you know on behalf of myself and
the rest of the organizers
um
i believe there's like a cinco de mayo
celebration happening outside so
everyone should go and uh enjoy that but
yeah let's just say yeah thanks again
for coming
[Applause]
yeah hopefully this uh leads to some
more interesting